as we bid farewell to 2020 there are so
many great things to look forward to
in the new year joining me to discuss
all the exciting things coming in 2021
is ash crossin
and melissa johnson ladies some good
stuff coming up next year ash
kick things off what are you looking
forward to in 2021
yeah hopefully um i'm looking forward to
returning to
the movie theater because we have a
giant
backlog of movies that we should have
seen already that are going to get their
releases
uh next year black widow the eternals
just name a few but then
uh recently wb just announced that not
only are they going to be releasing
their movies in 2021 no more shuffling
around
they're going to be releasing them
simultaneously in theaters and on hbo
max which means that we are
100 getting at least the wb movies next
year so we're gonna be getting stuff
like godzilla vs kong
uh mortal kombat in the heights space
jam
a new legacy the suicide squad dune
and matrix four just to name a few so
we're getting movies yeah
i think that this just shows how much
the movie industry has
learned from this pandemic they've
learned that streaming these films
works you said that wb is going to
release their films in theaters and also
on hbo max i think that just speaks to
what the statistics have shown that some
people would like to stay at home
and watch the films they can also get
money that way but also
of course you have people like yourself
ash that are just dying to get back in
the films
and to the movie theaters the reality
actually is that you know the pandemic
isn't going anywhere
and it's certainly i think gonna be um
as far as
you know us being able to see movies
it's gonna be the same next year too
so i feel like warner brothers um
honestly did the right thing
by making them available for people to
stream so we could still watch them uh
you know what i mean it's just like
it's gonna be a minute i trust me i miss
going to the movie theaters like the
whole experience okay like literally
them
skating my ticket me getting my popcorn
me finding my seat in the dark because
i'm always late i miss all that you know
what i mean but
there's still pandemic going on and so
i'd rather be able to watch it when it's
supposed to release in the comforts of
my home and my sweats you know what i'm
saying
same same contingency plan yes
i'll take it one of the things that i'm
looking forward to next year
the weekend is uh set to headline the
halftime show
and if you've seen his live performances
at a few of the award shows this past
year like the video music awards like
the american music awards
this guy knows how to put on a show i've
seen him at coachella twice
like this he brings it it's a dynamic
performance with such an amazing voice
and when you get a gig like
super bowl you know all the coin goes
into this all your time
energy uh goes into this performance
because it's you know it's
career making and so i can't wait to see
what he pulls out the question is is
like
do we think it'll just be the weekend or
will he have some surprise guests
i think surprise guests you know i'm
looking forward to seeing his face
his handsome face can we let go of the
bandages and the scars the weekend
i'm all for allegedly what his purpose
is behind doing
it but i want to see something different
and i'm sure he's gonna switch it up
it's a new year
maybe he'll bring us something
interesting and new
i agree i think you know i cover movies
here at entertainment tonight and uh
the weekend gives us cinema like
that guy puts together a full
feature-length film through his music
videos and his performances so
he is not going to put together like
your run-of-the-mill show there's no way
and i think
you know they're putting a lot more
thought into who they're getting in
these super bowl halftime shows like
i think last year with um jlo and
shakira was one of the best super
bowl halftime shows in a long time
so getting somebody like the weekend you
they know it they're gonna get uh he's
gonna do so oh i can't wait
to thank for that we have jay-z's rock
nation to thank for that they're
the sixth generation yeah they have been
deciding who's gonna perform and
so far they're two for two so i can't
wait for that uh malicious what are you
looking forward to
in 2021 well speaking of the super bowl
i'm super excited to see queen latifah
star
in the reboot of the television series
the equalizer
which will air right after the big game
on cbs
it's prime time placement so i think
that speaks volume to what we're about
to get
from this series the show follows an
ex-cia agent and a single mother
robin mccall who's played by queen
latifah she uses her extensive skills to
help those
who have nowhere else to turn now this
is a series that originally aired in the
1980s and of course over the years we
saw
denzel washington take on the role in
the movie
and film space so i'm really interested
to see how the queen
is going to approach this new role of
hers
i love that it's a role that we've never
really seen her in um so i'm excited
that you know it's new territory and
she's going to be in a series like a
series regular on tv but
ash i don't know if you agree with me
here i'm kind of bummed that that
probably means we're not getting a
bringing down the house sequel
with steve martin so i why not
why not why do you think that denny cuz
to be in a tv show is a huge commitment
that schedule is like anything other
it's not like a movie where you just
knock it out like you know what i mean
especially on cbs
ash it's such a funny priority
down the house too now i guess i need it
but at least we do get some queen
latifah because you know she's she's the
best
come on you're not fooling anybody
and as we wrap up the year we wanted to
take a look back at some
inspiring words of hope and wisdom from
some of your favorite celebrities who
evidently are also looking forward to
2021. meryl what are you looking forward
to in 2021
[Laughter]
the inauguration
i hear you what about you james um
it's difficult to look past the
inauguration really i
sort of right now i'm talking to you
from the basement in my house i'm
looking forward
to any day that i'm alive
so i'm looking forward to all of 2021
that if
we come to a point where we're back to
any sense of normality
that we really take a moment to not
start to take it all for granted
joe what about you what are you looking
forward to young lady
honestly i am looking forward to
when broadway and live entertainment
comes roaring back
hopefully it's in 20 20 21 but i
i cannot wait to get back to the theater
when it's safe and get a
big standing ovation well it's weird
let's let's go
look for the ball drops let's go to the
vaccine that it works for everybody
once that's there once that's all behind
you that's what i'm looking forward to
what does 2021 look like for bad bunny
whoa for the 20 21
i think that right now my big
biggest dream is make a concert
with a lot of people
[Music]
that's the only thing that i want you
know i i know that
it's hard but i don't know that's my
only
goal right now really 2020 has been
really challenging but i will say there
have been some discoveries in 2020 a lot
of us have been forced to prioritize the
relationships and the
parts of life that really matter to us
and i'm looking forward to
bringing some of that wisdom into 2021
with me
what brought me joy this year was two
things actually
being able to spend more time with my
family number one
and just being able to get some sleep
just reboot spiritually we all should
be looking forward to the idea that
there is light at the end of this tunnel
you know there is probably by uh
late spring early summer we'll be
getting a lot more people vaccinated
than just the essential workers who've
been amazing you just want everybody to
hang in there and
and you know it's tough and it's brutal
and all of those things
is tough on the economy it's all of that
and the
you know the government should help out
for everyone who's who's having a
difficult time
we're close and when we're there we're
gonna you know we'll be able to
we'll be able to be in the same room
again and uh which would be fantastic
2020 has been a tough year what do you
wish for all of us for 2021
uh i i i want this to be over it will be
over
uh i want everyone to remember this year
and then go yeah this is uh and all the
all those little things that we took for
granted
you know uh we won't take for granted
anymore and uh
and we love our family and our friends
so much and we're lucky to have anything
in any of this uh readership i'm excited
about
maxine i'm excited about people's lives
being saved
i'm excited about people being able to
really just relax into
um something somewhat of safety again
i really think that things are going to
change for the better i'm very positive
about it well i have
my son gary gary lee so he
right before the pandemic
he came to permanently live with us and
he is an amazing
young man a little boy i think gary
coming to
live with us and become one of our crazy
family is probably hands down the best
thing
this whole here is like a blur for all
of us that
i'm like i don't even know if i'm
allowed to have hopes and dreams in 2021
because
they were all just canceled in 2020.
um honestly though i just i really
i pray for everyone's health and not
just for my immediate family
but the world i just pray that 2020
brings
us health and and reconciliation
on a global level i'm looking forward to
getting together with
my buddies i'm looking forward to going
to concerts i'm looking forward to going
back to restaurants
uh it's right around the corner you know
this has been a trying year for
everybody
and uh you know for me it's been an
opportunity to sort of reboot
and um you know i'm i'm looking forward
to 2021
sailor v2020 well you know we made it
this far so hopefully there's some
advice there that we can all cling on to
to get us through until next year until
then ash malicia thank you so much for
joining us